y ustedes compran un camión a 60 mil
dólares para comenzar un negocio de
envíos el camión tiene una vida útil de
3 años y después ustedes tienen que
comprar otro camión lo que he puesto
aquí es dibujar nuestros estados de
cuenta de ingresos para este negocio de
envíos aquí está el año 1 el año 2 3 4 5
etcétera esos son los ingresos que
obtenemos por año y vemos que desde el
primer año tenemos 100 mil dólares de
ingresos por lo que es un negocio que
comienza a ganar desde el principio
todas estas cantidades están en miles de
dólares todo en miles y vemos que ese
negocio es muy estable genera 100 mil
dólares de ingreso cada año al menos
durante los primeros 10 años y también
tenemos que pagarle al conductor digamos
que el costo laboral es de 50 mil
dólares aquí también son miles de
dólares al año y lo que quiero que
veamos en este vídeo es que bueno este
es un costo se lo vamos a restar a
nuestros ingresos por lo que nos van a
quedar 50 mil dólares y nuestro otro
costo va a ser nuestro camión lo que
quiero que pensemos es como debemos
contabilizar este camión o los gastos de
este camión en nuestro estado de cuenta
y ustedes me pueden decir oye
de entrada yo gasté 60 mil dólares para
comprar el camión por lo que en el
primer año vamos a la concesionaria a
comprar un camión porque no lo pongo
como un gasto de 60 mil así que por una
parte ustedes podrían decir bueno aquí
en este año gasté 60 mil dólares
comprando el camión en el segundo año no
tengo que comprar camión porque ya lo
tengo en el tercer año tampoco tengo que
comprarlo pero en el cuarto año mi
primer camión ha dado todo lo que podía
y lo tengo que desechar así que en el
cuarto año tengo que comprar otro camión
de 60 mil dólares nuevamente en el
quinto y sexto año lo tengo que comprar
camión pero en el séptimo año si otro
camión de 60 mil dólares en los años 89
no tengo que comprar camión en el décimo
año tengo que comprar nuevamente camión
de 60 mil dólares si toman en cuenta la
compra de su camión cada tres años de
esta manera las ganancias se verán así
en el primer año tenemos 100 que es
nuestro ingreso menos estos dos que son
gastos 100 menos 50 menos 60 nos queda
una ganancia negativa de 10 mil
en este primer año en el segundo año
tenemos 50.000 en el tercero también
obtenemos 50.000 100 menos 50 y en el
cuarto año de nuevo menos 10.000 dólares
en los años 5 y 6 ganamos 50.000 dólares
y de nuevo menos 10 mil dólares y así
sucesivamente para alguien que vea esta
serie de estados de cuenta de ingresos
pues van a decir caray
este es un negocio muy extraño en el
primer año y a partir de ahí cada tres
años pierden muchísimo dinero no sé por
qué quizás no lo están manejando bien o
algo extraño está pasando y en los
siguientes años hacen mucho dinero
pierden dinero y ganan dinero parece un
negocio realmente muy extraño al menos
desde el punto de vista de las
operaciones de ganancia y en los años en
donde se gasta para comprar el camión
las operaciones de ganancia son las
ganancias que vienen de las operaciones
antes de ver cómo es que pagamos por
estas operaciones como las financiamos
los impuestos etcétera pero esto es
extraño porque realmente es un negocio
muy estable desde el punto de vista de
las operaciones de ganancia
saltos de pérdida ganancia perdida
ganancia la forma en que nosotros
reconciliamos esto es hacer algo llamado
capitalizar el gasto del camión y
después de apreciarlo durante el tiempo
que sea su vida útil y eso lo veremos en
el siguiente vídeo